barely covered the johnny depp trial but
i'm gonna we're gonna milk this tom
hanks yeah yeah tummings have an anger
oh my god
greet us to blame reid
what's happening there reject nation
we're trying out these microphones right
now this is the fourth new mic in the
last few weeks
we're doing whatever we can to master
this
and uh we said
let's kick it off with seeing tom hanks
yelling at people apparently that's the
best way to break in any new piece of
equipment is to watch somebody in the
heat of a moment of personal anguish uh
i wonder why uh let's see what's going
on leave a like
leave a like for captain phillips
let's do
[Music]
some items how are you this it's been a
long time be careful time watch out move
move
on a long time
celebrities and their wives
you're the reason no rules apply billy
bush yeah it's your fault trump said
those things
you made him do it shut up you evil
puppet master you oh dang i love how
they have the people like right behind
them and the people like who ostensibly
are holding this camera being like sorry
tom man i don't know what they're crazy
when you're like dude you're part of the
throng that's contributing to this in
the first place let's watch that again i
want to see what exactly happened i
gotta look out for rita
man celebs men never will smith he's
done some
both will smith and tom hanks two people
who are known to be
insanely nice individuals america's dad
and big brother now yelling at people
and getting pissed off
just because their wife gets gets a
little humiliated in public
[Laughter]
you know people got to be standing up
for that no man i totally get it
especially especially
you're being swarmed and bombarded i'd
be pissed too i'd be totally pissed
i'd be like why didn't you push her down
harder could have gotten out of this
decades with this woman
um anyway there's still time let's do
this again it would have been bad if he
like
laughed about it at first like will
smith
i mean idiot she tripped i mean what did
you do
in an alternate universe he slapped
everyone there just one after the other
let's see this
i look at him he's in such a good mood
how are you doing
be careful
okay he has the guy in the blue shirt
yeah
whoa whoa whoa
[Music]
he's singling out that one guy and he
didn't even do it i can't tell if that
dude yeah it looks like that dude he was
like he was like two people behind
look at this unless the argument is that
he like pushed the other guy into it he
didn't look at it he didn't do it
like watch the guy in the blue shirt he
didn't do anything like way back there
he's like three oh my god he is he's
like two or three people behind and he's
taking it out on the way he literally
it's the the dude in the lakers hat
who's right behind her and he's the one
who kind of got too close to her and
there's another dude in a blue shirt
with a camera who's like right on top of
her but yeah that guy they panty is like
four people who looks like freaking sid
from toy story kid who's like three
people behind
you i can't believe you you know you
know it's it's it's a whole group you
just got to pick a figurehead for the
group and that kid you know he thought
you know long and hard who best
represents this whole batch of people
it's that guy
obviously it's that kid
i mean i know he's like heated this must
be especially shocking from a fan
perspective when
you know tom hanks to be just the
coolest dude in the world mr yeah calm
and collected makes anybody feel
comforted you know and and yet here he
is losing his cool but i don't know i
mean this is as far as celebrity
scandals go this is among the more sort
of yeah i mean i i get it in the heat of
a moment this could have been worse you
see the headliner you're like whoa did
tom hanks just lose it on some
well-meaning fan but you know it's this
is a a bit of a difference case you know
personal space is being violated when
it's protecting a fan too
i think a guy who caught the vid before
would not want to be surrounded by a
bunch of strangers
yeah
massless look out tom dude you were you
were the poster child for safety back in
the deal i kind of started saying that
to people back up
yeah dude i love how extra decided to to
to like we own this video ourselves yeah
but what is this
we own censorship
of celebrities embarrassing moments
really
see their freaking
logo pop up there that's so funny yeah
we should start doing that whenever we
swears put the real rejects logo or like
the patreon link or whoever's sponsoring
this video personal
connected to the fans how would you like
your censorship portrayed on screen let
us know i'm surprised i didn't see this
go trending on twitter
dude you're not on twitter enough
yeah you should be on twitter more i'm
trying to be on twitter all waking hours
so you never miss a trend no i think
actually in all sincerity tom hanks
handled that really well yeah i mean you
know
i mean he just yelled and told him to
back off and his wife's being pushed
over of course yeah i mean but the other
part of his like it looks like she kind
of tripped yeah on her own heel it
didn't seem quite as like there's a mob
and this is turning into chaos and
they're trampling on like yeah it seemed
like people got too close and yeah like
maybe she tripped or something or or
you know
things can get exacerbated pretty easily
and watch rita again really quick
i mean
watch her
it was real
someone does yeah definitely like walked
right in here
[Laughter]
i mean i think anybody in that position
if you bumped anybody especially tom
hanks's wife
either yeah yeah i mean it it seems kind
of like a an
honest uh situation born of maybe a bit
too much enthusiasm it looked like like
the at least one guy was looking at tom
and walked right into reed wilson or
whatever but yeah immediately just be
like it's all these people i'm like i
mean
you pumped are pretty good i just feel
pretty bad for that one guy because i'm
like everyone just three times and every
time watching like
like make sure we know this guy's face
is so mortified by the situation that's
good
that poor guy he's beautiful always like
this is the moment in time that tom
hanks will like just you know he
did something else that night and forgot
about it but that one kid is just like
haunted forever by that moment if i ever
meet him again i cannot say anything
yeah shouldn't go up to him
oh dude instantly
oh terrible so good
more of these we need more of this
content all right guys well
what do you think i guess that's the
question who's in the right
uh leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell
this is where we are more celebrity
drama
barely covered the johnny depp trial but
i'm gonna we're gonna milk the [ __ ] out
of this tom hanks yeah yeah tummings
have an anger
oh my god hank's house greet us to blame
reid told him to go off on those people
even before they left the hotel she was
like these people can't get away without
a reprimand from you the way she looked
at him that provoked stuff
yeah
america's father must be a stern father
uncompromising
all right guys i'll see you soon